[Music]
on this Sunday night breaking news a
snowbird plane crashes in BC Norway the
tragedy for Canada's military you see a
plane to the sky what witnesses saw as
the plane went down in a residential
neighborhood our Canadians ready to
venture out into this brave new world as
the reopening begins plus plenty of
lobsters but a shortage of labour
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with breaking news out of
British Columbia tonight where a
snowbird jet belonging to the Canadian
military has crashed Global News can
confirm that one member of the team is
dead another ejected from the cockpit
landed on a house and is in stable
condition in hospital this video
captured by witnesses shows two planes
were in unison then one started to climb
gaining altitude before spiraling to the
ground the plane went down in a
residential neighborhood in Kamloops BC
when they took off it if the one kind of
deviated and went off by itself it looks
like they're just gonna have some fun or
whatever stolen I once heard going
upside down angled over I heard the guy
in the truck beside me he goes no
they're serious and then you could see
the pilots ejecting and that didn't look
there very high off the ground let's
bring in our auto a beauty mercedes
stevenson mercedes you've learned the
identity of the person who was killed
yeah Robin I'm sorry to report it is
captain Jennifer
Casey she was the public affairs officer
for the snowbirds team I can tell you
she's someone we dealt with an awful lot
as media just a fantastic woman she was
a former broadcaster herself she joined
the military became an officer and she
was traveling with the snowbirds as the
public affairs officers do it's their
job to do all the media and community
relations for the team she was on board
that plane that went down her family has
been notified of this tragedy again the
victim in this crash is Captain Jennifer
Casey the snowbirds public affairs
officer the male pilot who was flying
the plane who we are not identifying at
this point survived he was injured he
was transported to hospital where he is
stable he ended up landing on a roof
they did not have a lot of time to eject
from the plane it was quite low you see
it pull up very quickly after takeoff
where it appears to lose thrust for some
reason I've spoken to a number of pilots
who see the maneuver you see happening
there is one that is executed
when a pilot is trying to gain altitude
because they've lost airspeed gives them
more time to potentially eject or to try
to land the plane and in this case we do
know that the pilot ejected so we don't
know the cause of this yet we don't know
the reason this happened but obviously a
terrible tragedy for the military and
for the Air Force this is the second
death that they have had in just a
couple of weeks of course the cyclone
known as the stalker went down in the
Ionian Sea on April 29th Mercedes we
know that this was a cross-country tour
to promote inspiration and inspire
Canadians because of the Cova 19 crisis
but there have been concerns about the
safety of these planes for years given
their age and previous crashes where any
concerns raised at any point during
Operation inspiration I don't know about
during this particular operation Robin
but there have been ongoing concerns
from the crews over the years and from
members of the Canadian Forces about the
age of these planes they're actually
built in the 1960s to give you an idea
of how old they are there have been
numerous crashes before seven pilots
have died in crashes in the past the
most recent crash was in October of 2019
the pilot survived that one by ejecting
but they're questions about the ejection
seat and the engine now the report on
what happened in that crash has not yet
been completed so we don't know and of
course it's important to say we don't
know what the cause of today's crash was
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
Mercedes in other news almost a dozen
firefighters in Los Angeles are
recovering tonight after being hurt in
an explosion the blast created a
fireball so intense it melted the
firefighters coats helmets and scorched
a fire truck across the street as
Jennifer Johnson explains more than 200
firefighters had to be called out to get
this fire under control downtown Los
Angeles filled with smoke after a
one-story building fire created a
massive fireball that shot into the air
and Street witnesses thought they heard
multiple explosions if you felt like it
was a series like there was definitely
one main one but it felt like as it kept
going there were more first responders
describe the boom as a freight train or
jet engine shaking the block now they're
inside this building where the smoke is
active it was a worst-case scenario for
firefighter
the business was a supplier of butane
honey oil used in making concentrated
cannabis
fortunately the lead officer quickly
detected danger the smoke pressure was
escalating the the heat was increasing
in the rear of the occupancy he directed
every to immediately get out of the
building that order saved their lives
and a flash while they made their way
out an explosion erupted from the
building first responders sent out a
mayday call the blaze was so intense
witnesses saw firefighters coming down
the aerial ladder from the roof with
their protective coats and helmets on
fire this could have been horrendous
and all the firefighters that came in
were awake and alert and talking when
they came in which is a great sign
fortunately the area was not filled with
people as Los Angeles remains mostly
locked down due to Coba 19 the injured
firefighters are expected to be ok good
news is everybody's gonna make it got a
lot of firefighters that are shaken up
the cause of the blaze is still unclear
LA's fire chief knows this could have
been a deadly call for his firefighters
in a city that has already been on edge
for months Jennifer Johnson Global News
Washington
now to the other big story the Cova 19
crisis in Canada here's a look at the
breakdown of cases close to 77,000
people have contracted Cova 19 in this
country tonight there are still more
than 32,000 active cases of Cova 19 the
good news is that more than half the
patients have recovered from the virus
Quebec is the hardest hit province it
recorded more than 700 new cases today
and 79 more people died in just 24 hours
more businesses are set to reopen next
week but it will look very different
from what we're used to restaurants and
retail services in BC are preparing to
welcome customers back with Plexiglas
installed at dining tables and at
checkout counters there will be regular
deep cleaning and staff will be donning
masks as they serve patrons while many
Canadians are itching for more freedom
will they be willing to step out and
resume regular activities as Mike Joe
Lee reports
it depends on what those activity
our call it testing the waters all
across the country Canadians are dipping
their toes and freedoms we've taken for
granted
Toronto closed many of its streets in
the name of biking in fresh air while
golfers took to the links I've been I've
been itching in record numbers we sold
out within minutes of opening our online
booking it speaks to how long we've been
living in isolation in new poll
conducted by Ipsos on behalf of Global
News the results are clear Canadians
want out it's no surprise as Calgary
mall had a line up when it opened
because that's where 63% of Canadians
said they'd like to go and Edmonton
patios were clearly humming for a reason
60 percent say they can't wait to go to
a restaurant it's been a long time we
certainly needed it that's for sure but
the polling also shows Canadians haven't
forgotten the reason we've been in
isolation so long I'm not one of the
people who think that we should open up
quite yet kovat 19 is still a very real
threat which is why only 32 percent say
they'd stay in a hotel and 18% would go
to a sporting event in what could be a
preview of NHL NBA in baseball games in
North America the German Bundesliga
kicked off with nary a fan in the stands
although the supporters of one team made
12,000 cutouts of themselves to make the
players feel less alone and when Danish
singer Mads Langer performed at a
drive-in he showed this summer may not
be completely lost when it comes to
concerts especially when considering 22
percent of Canadians feel comfortable
going to live shows right now how many
people are gonna want to go to a show
where they could come into close
proximity with sweaty strangers who may
be infected that's the bigger problem
Toronto banned July talk has a couple of
drive-in shows planned for August and
other bands are planning similar shows
in BC it frankly is better than nothing
I mean it's great to be able to see
these virtual shows using Skype and zoom
and for YouTube and Instagram and all
their Oliver stuff but there's nothing
that can really replace the atmosphere
of a live performance with you actually
being there with other like-minded
people and the sad truth is it could be
a year or longer before concerts and
arenas start looking normal again so we
might as well get used to it
microlight Global News Toronto lobster
season is officially underway in the
mayor of time it was delayed by two
weeks because of covin 19 but seafood
processors in New Brunswick say they
will struggle to stay afloat because of
a labor shortage the province has banned
temporary foreign workers who would
normally help during the fishing season
and as frost Lord reports Canada's
billion-dollar lobster industry fears
the losses could be enormous at lobster
processing plants in New Brunswick up to
half the seasonal workforce is typically
recruited from countries like Mexico and
Jamaica with New Brunswick's kovat 19
measures banning temporary foreign
workers plants are half-empty desperate
plant managers are turning to teenagers
whose classes have been canceled by the
pandemic my son's 13 and he came to work
two weeks ago and know a lot of his
friends came and the word got around
they say they're still short-handed now
that the season in southeast New
Brunswick is underway fishers can only
sell half as much lobster as they'd like
because that's all the plants can
convert into retail products processors
suggest Premier Blaine Higgs foreign
worker ban is making a tough time for
the lobster industry even worse he was
thinking he was protecting the citizens
and he thought that there'll be enough
New Brunswickers that would be willing
to come to work and that's where he was
mistaken premiere Higgs admits he's
disappointed you know I think it's a sad
commentary on our province if we have
70,000 people unemployed and that
basically we're not able to find enough
people to work in the opportunities that
exist it tells us something about our
challenges we have as a province maybe
as a nation the federal government has
announced up to a half billion dollars
in support to fish harvesters but New
Brunswick plants doubt that help will
arrive in time they say some product
will end up going to other provinces
that still hire temporary foreign
workers
Ross Laura Global News Windsor Nova
Scotia America's biggest cities have
seen large numbers of people being
infected by this pernicious virus one of
the hardest hit populations is the
Navajo Nation they span across three
states and have more than 3,100 cases
the highest per capita rate of
coronavirus infection anywhere in the US
regi Cecchini reports lost in the
spotlight of the seemingly endless
outbreaks in urban areas a deadly battle
is underway deep in the desert we got to
stay vigilant
America's Navajo Nation one of the
oldest indigenous reservations in the
country is sinking under the weight of
the virus tribal nations the first
citizens are put on the bottom of the
list that seems to us we spoke to the
nation's President Jonathan Nez in April
when there were 698 positive cases today
the infection rate per capita is now the
highest in America covering just over
77,000 square kilometers over three
states Navajo Nation has a population of
175,000 and is roughly the size of New
Brunswick we just want everybody to
recognize that tribal communities are in
need of assistance as well our studies
have shown people of color are at a
heightened risk of contracting this
virus Navajo residents suffer from high
rates of diabetes and hypertension but
money and access to care is limited
federal funding to reservations is often
slow to move infrastructure is poor the
region is a food desert meaning
residents drive to larger cities putting
themselves at risk at home basic
mitigation efforts like hand-washing
are often impossible 30% of the homes on
Navajo Nation don't have running water
so how are they gonna do that in a rare
move Doctors Without Borders has been
dispatched on American soil telling
global news in a statement their team is
providing training on infection
prevention and control adding they will
help expand contact tracing their
presence in the u.s. is a first the
organization typically assists in war
ravaged and low-income nations a
two trillion dollar stimulus package
approved in March will provide more than
half a billion dollars in aid to the
Navajo but local leaders say it's too
little and far too late
tribal nations have contributed a lot to
this country and we're just saying that
we want our share of resources Kovach 19
adding yet another challenge in the
ongoing struggle to maintain
independence and equality across
American reservations
Reggie kini Global News Washington
brazil's president has been slammed for
not taking the pandemic seriously that
country has 233 thousand cases of Kovan
19 the fourth highest number of cases in
the world other Latin American countries
that are locked down are also struggling
Peru took action early shutting down
borders in March and even limiting which
days people could leave their homes it
now has more than 80,000 kovin 19 cases
and there's particular concern about the
spread of the corona virus in markets at
one produce market in the capital 79% of
vendors have tested positive for the
illness and then there's El Salvador it
enacted some of the toughest Kovan 19
restrictions even before it had a single
case it now has about 1300 human rights
groups have accused the president of
abusing power amid the pandemic more
than 7,000 people have been detained in
cramped containment centers after
returning to the country or for
violating quarantine measures it's fear
the virus is spreading among the
detainees but the government isn't
revealing how many of them have tested
positive or how many have died coming up
between an activist and a former
president their messages to the class of
2020
normally this time of year is filled
with graduation events instead the class
of 2020 is taking part in a virtual
graduation tonight we honor 12 years of
your hard work
this special called graduate together
America honors the high school class of
2020 was hosted by NBA star LeBron James
a number of musicians actors and
activists came together last night to
celebrate grads including Malala
yousufzai the class of 2020 won't be
defined by what we lost to his finest
but by how we responded to it the world
is yours now
former US President Barack Obama had the
final remarks of the night in his speech
he called on graduates to shape the
future he also took a dig at his
successor you know all those adults they
used to think or in charge and knew what
they were doing turns out they don't
have all the answers do what you think
is right doing what feels good what's
convenient what's easy that's how little
kids think unfortunately a lot of
so-called grown-ups including some with
fancy titles and important jobs still
think that way which is why things are
so screwed up still ahead we continue
our coverage of the snow brutes crash
NBC what more we're learning about this
tragedy for the Canadian military
returning to our top story a Canadian
snowbirds plane which was part of a
military flyover across Canada has
crashed in BC it happened in Kamloops a
city located in the interior of the
province this is the shocking and
dramatic footage caught by witnesses on
the ground
it appears the two Jets were in unison
then one turned and started to climb
gaining altitude before spiralling to
the ground it went down in a residential
neighborhood and hit a house Armas they
are Mercedes Stephenson has been talking
to her military sources and we now have
an identity of the person who was killed
yeah Robyn very sad to report that it's
captain Jennifer Casey she was the
public affairs officer for the unit
those of us in the media dealt with her
a lot and she was a respected journalist
before she joined the military to serve
her country doubling down on this
tragedy of it not only being the second
major air accident within just over two
weeks for the Canadian Air Force on top
of that captain casey was from nova
scotia a province that has already
suffered so much grief in the past month
were there any concerns about the safety
of these planes given previous crashes
and the age of these planes it's
certainly something that's been raised a
number of times there's concern about
them because they were built in the
1960s and to be clear here Robin these
are really incredibly skilled pilots I
mean they are the airshow team and
incredibly skilled maintained errs who
keep these in the air but they are
planes that were built in the 1960s and
there have been concerns about both the
engines and the ejection seats in the
past we don't know what caused this
crash it could have been anything from
an engine failure to a bird strike all
we know is that it happened and we're
still trying to figure out what I can
tell you by the way Robin that right now
there is a flight safety investigation
team from the Canadian Forces on their
way to BC Mercedes Stephenson in Ottawa
and global national we'll be back after
this short break
you are watching global national around
the world millions are turning to faith
for answers in this difficult time but
the way they pray has changed because
many places are either closed or have
limited numbers but as Redman Shannon
reports the pandemic hasn't stopped them
from finding new ways to practice what
they preach and to pay it forward the
kitchen at this Sikh temple in Surrey BC
has been home to a key ingredient of
worship since the start of the pandemic
volunteering for the groceries for the
food and the quest some of these
volunteers are here partly because
they're out of work themselves now
they're delivering tens of thousands of
meals to the isolated and to frontline
workers a new way to exercise their
faith in a good whare that can only
accept 15 worshippers a day we feel
actually very happy in this time at
least we help the peoples we help to
each other we have to take care each
other so I feel proud technology has
truly been a godsend for those who were
isolating watching online is the next
best thing to gathering at a temple a
mosque or a church this ancient church
in London was at the epicenter of the
city's Great Plague of 1665 one that
killed 20% of the city's population
Reverend cannon Allison Joyce is
inspired by her predecessor from that
time Richard Pierson many clergy fled
the city Richard Pearson who was vicar
here at Sand bride's during that time
was one of very very few who actually
chose to remain his bravery informs
cannon Joyce's Sunday Sermons the audio
broadcast around the world from this
empty church we found our congregation
is actually growing remarkably and it's
also reaching people internationally
which we haven't expected and I think
we're not alone in that Canon Joyce says
when worshipers return some
difficult decisions need to be made
particularly when it comes to
administering Holy Communion we're
learning to do ministry in a completely
different way and we're learning lessons
that like many churches will take
forward into the future as well this
universal struggle is testing how people
worship but not the depth of their faith
Redman Shannon Global News London and
that is global national for this Sunday
I'm Robin Gill tomorrow I'll be
reporting from Kamloops BC on that
tragic snowbirds crash Donna fries and
we'll be at the anchor desk thank you
for joining us good night
[Music]
you